everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today
solving validate binary search a very
good question for practicing binary
search tree questions we're just given a
root of a binary search tree and we just
want to determine
is it a valid binary search tree or not
and from learning data structures and
algorithms you might know that a valid
binary search tree
is such that we have a node
like two and every every
single node in the left subtree one
and if it possibly had other children is
going to be
less than two right so one is going to
be
less than two and similarly every single
value in the right subtree three
including three's potential children's
if it had any
are going to be greater than
two not greater or equal strictly
greater and we know this is a recursive
definition so if
we had three and it had some children
like
five and maybe four over here we see
that it's not
a binary search tree because four
should be less than three four should be
less than three but it's not
so this is not a binary search tree so
we need to do
a recursive depth first search to solve
this problem
but let me show you what you might try
you might just try
a simple solution like hey five we have
five is the root
let's check its child okay three is less
than five that's good
okay let's check the right child okay
seven is greater than five that's good
right
okay let's now let's check seven because
we see three
it doesn't have any children that's good
for us we don't have to check anything
but
seven has a left child it has four as a
left child well
that's good four is less than seven
and it has a right child eight that's
good
eight is greater than seven so is this a
binary search tree
the answer is no because
it's really easy to miss we have a 5 as
the root
we have a right subtree over here and we
have a
4 in the right subtree
but we know 5 is not less than 4
that's not true so we need a better
algorithm
and it requires depth first search we
can't
just check the neighbors so our brute
force approach would be
for five check every value in its left
subtree make sure that it's
every value is less than five and then
check every value
in the right subtree make sure five is
less than every value in the right
subtree
and so we would need n comparisons to do
that right
o of n and then we'd have to repeat that
process for
every sub tree so seven we got to repeat
that compare it to
every potential descendant of itself
which is going to be o of n and the time
complexity of that
overall is going to be o n squared so
can we do
better than o of n squared so one
thing to notice is the root value can be
any value right there's no restrictions
on what the value can be
because it doesn't have any parents so
we can say that
it can be any value between negative
infinity
and positive infinity and as long as
that's the case five is okay we don't
have to make
any other comparisons five is between
negative infinity and positive infinity
okay and then
when we go down to the left subtree we
know five is good we don't even have to
check it anymore
but when we go down to the left subtree
what do we have to
check all we have to check is that 3
is less than 5 so in other words
we just want to make sure three is
greater than a negative infinity which
of course it is
and we're adding one more condition we
want to make sure
it's less than five so
our left boundary stayed the same but we
had to update
our right boundary from up here
right and so we're done with that and of
course we don't have any children
for three and five of course we don't
have any children for three so
we are done checking three next
we want to also determine that the right
subtree
is a binary search tree so we want to
make sure seven
is greater than five but is there an
upper boundary for seven like this could
have been a hundred
or could have been anything so there's
no upper boundary yet
so we just need to check that seven is
less than infinity
meaning that this is the right boundary
and it's greater than
5 so we had to update the left boundary
over here when we went
here we only had to update the right
boundary
and this condition is true so
we are done checking 7 it is satisfied
and when we go to the right child 8
we're going to do the same thing we only
have to
update the left boundary so we have to
make sure that 8 is at least
greater than 7 but it could be
anything so it's less than infinity so
that's good
8 is a binary search tree
but now we get to the value that
actually
breaks our binary search tree and let's
see what our algorithm
does so we know since set four is the
left child of seven
it should be less than seven
four is less than seven
we have to update the right boundary for
four
but the left boundary stays the same
so we're getting the left boundary from
over here we're borrowing it from its
parent
because if seven is greater than 5
then it's left child and 4 is a part of
the sub tree 4 must
also be greater than 5 so the left
boundary is 5. now
does this condition hold it does
not 4 is not between
7 and 5 so this value breaks
our binary search tree so therefore this
is not a binary search tree
it's false we're returning false and
with this algorithm since for each
node all we're really doing is making a
comparison
we're making a single or rather two
comparisons this is going to be
big o of n or uh 2n
which we know is still linear so we can
just call it big
o of n so now it's actually time to
write the algorithm and the best way to
do this
is recursively so that's what i'm going
to do i'm going to write a helper
function
nested inside of this helper or inside
of our original
function we'll call it valid we know we
need to pass
in the node since we are going to do
this recursively and we're going to have
two boundaries
left and right boundaries like any
binary search recursive function
if we reach a null node we can just
return what are we going to return
we're going to return true because
technically an empty binary search tree
is still a binary search tree and then
we want to check
we want to make sure that node value is
less than the right boundary
and node value is greater than the left
boundary
but we know if this is not true if
these conditions do not satisfy then
we have to return false because we found
a node that
broke our binary search tree and now
it's time to make
our recursive call so we want to make
sure that the left subtree of node
is valid so we can pass node.left and
what's going to be the boundary
for these well since we are going left
we can leave the left boundary the same
but we're going to
update the right boundary to the node's
value because we know
that a left sub tree has to be less than
every value we know every value in the
left sub tree has to be
less than the parent and so the parent
is going to be set
to the right boundary because we need we
need to make sure that this is going to
be
less than that so we want to make sure
that the left sub tree is valid we
also want to make sure that the right
subtree
is valid and in this case we're going to
do the opposite of what we just did
so the left boundary is going to be
updated
and the right boundary is going to stay
the same because we know
every value in a right subtree has to be
greater than the root or the parent node
which is the left boundary and if both
of these return true
then we can return true if they both
return false
then we can return false so what we can
do is just
return the result of this so whatever
this evaluates to
is going to be our result we don't
really need any variables
and now we just need to call the
function that we just defined
valid we'll pass in the root we want to
make sure that this is a binary search
tree
initially the left boundary can be set
to negative infinity
and the right boundary can be set to
positive infinity because
the root value could be anything there's
no restrictions on what the root value
can be
and as you can see this is a super
efficient solution
beats 97 percent and it doesn't take
very much code either so i hope this was
helpful
if you enjoyed please like and subscribe
and support the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon